Speaker 1: One of the narratives that's been
built up by the right wing during the Biden
presidency, and in particular, they were they
were building this up during the lead up to
last week's Biden Putin summit was the Joe
Biden dimentia narrative.
It's not a new narrative.
Remember that back when the twenty twenty
Democratic primary was going on, when it got
down to just Joe Biden versus Bernie Sanders,
many right wingers and even some people on
the left were saying this is when Biden falls
apart.
This is when in a one on one debate against
Bernie Sanders, Joe Biden becomes completely
unable to put together a single coherent sentence.
And it just didn't happen, as we know.
But they've continued to push this narrative
during the Biden presidency.
Sometimes it's saying, you know, it's really
Kamala Harris who's running the show.
Biden can't do anything.
He's just you know, he's an empty suit and
someone else is controlling him.
Sometimes it's saying Biden can't do anything
without notes.
Imagine, right.
Being prepared for meetings.
That's what I call it.
And every single one of these claims that
now is when it'll really become clear.
Biden can't even he doesn't even know what
day it is every single time it fails to materialize.
But they were pushing it again for the Biden
Putin summit.
It didn't happen, but it also didn't happen.
And it didn't matter that it didn't happen
because in the aftermath, they were still
saying, whoa, did you see Biden really concerning
behavior?
And here is Ronnie Jackson.
This was Donald Trump's White House doctor
for a while now.
A Congressman, Ronnie Jackson, went on Fox
News and said, from what I'm seeing, Joe Biden
really needs a cognitive test, that Montreal
cognitive assessment that Trump took.
And then Ronnie says, remember, Trump got
a perfect score on that test and then walks
that back and says, well, he did really well.
Speaker 3: It was submitted to that.
President Trump, as you mentioned, he did
he had a perfect score on his cognitive tests
and outstanding performance.
And I'm just saying now I'm saying that is
the new standard the president has been set.
And I'm asking Joe Biden and his medical team
to get out there and to get this physical
exam done, get this cognitive testing done
and get the results back to the American people.
We need to know that we can trust our president.
Speaker 1: Now, there is just so much here
to talk about.
First of all, notice that Ronnie Jackson first
says Trump got a perfect score.
Then he walked it back and said, well, it
was an outstanding performance.
What he's referring to is when Donald Trump
took that Montreal cognitive assessment, which
is really meant to screen out serious dementia,
it's like, what city are you in?
Can you identify whether a drawing is a lizard
or a tiger? Trump didn't get a perfect score,
but even if Trump did get a perfect score,
it wouldn't tell us that much.
You're really supposed to get a near perfect
score unless you're seriously cognitively
struggling.
You give that test to people you suspect have
pretty serious dementia or they've suffered
a stroke and you want to evaluate how they're
doing cognitively at a high level or maybe
there's been a brain injury, et cetera.
The idea that Trump's near perfect score on
that test is now a baseline for evaluating
Joe Biden.
It's it's all a backwards series of events
saying Trump score was great on that.
So Biden should take it is like saying I got
a really good score on a drug test.
Well, it's like, no, you just weren't using
drugs.
There was the absence of a drug problem.
The test is meant to screen out the presence
or absence of serious cognitive issues.
If the new standard is knowing that a camel
isn't a shark and that, you know, we're in
Washington, D.C., then we're in real trouble.
And then for a doctor to go on TV and say
this bare bones test to rule out severe dementia
is now the standard for the presidency.
That's scary as well.
Now, let's get back to the Biden dementia
stuff.
I have been saying without any hesitation
or equivocation since day one of.
Joe Biden's 20 20 candidacy, Joe Biden is
not the same Joe Biden as in 2012 when he
debated and ran circles around Paul Ryan.
Joe Biden's speech has slowed down over the
last decade.
Joe Biden is almost 80 years old.
I've conceded that as if it's even really
a concession.
I've also talked about how Joe Biden's lifelong
stutter, combined with him being nearly 80
and just talking more slowly now, could make
it seem as though maybe he's not one hundred
percent clear in his mind all the time.
I have no interest in gaslighting.
It can appear that way when you combine the
slowed down speech with the stutter.
But when you see Biden given the opportunity
to lay out his thoughts in a normal setting,
you realize that the guy's memory easily recalls
even small details about conversations that
took place last week and about conversations
that took place last decade.
He has a full understanding of the context
of every issue he's asked about, and I have
no question right now about his ability to
do the job, particularly compared to Donald
Trump.
Orders of magnitude better now.
Is this the same guy that was Joe Biden debating
Paul Ryan in 2012?
Of course not.
And along the same lines, if you look at an
interview, at an interview that now I'm having
the issue at an interview that Trump did with
Dave Letterman 12 years ago, Trump's facility
with words, his vocabulary, his entire way
of speaking, has also shifted dramatically.
And one of the things you notice with Trump,
which can be a concerning sign, is his vocabulary
is so limited compared to how he spoke a decade
or two ago in those interviews with Dave Letterman
and others.
Now, if I thought Joe Biden was having a real
cognitive issue, I would just tell you I have
no more interest in having a president with
a cognitive issue than I guess any Republican
does, although they seemed not as worried
about it when Trump couldn't identify that
Rudy Giuliani was across the table from them
or couldn't identify that his limo was right
in front of him when he got off Air Force
One and walked down and had to be brought
back by Secret Service, or when he said he
wanted to get to the orange is of an investigation.
The same people now concerned about Biden
weren't concerned then.
I've called it like I've seen it all along.
But to hear this from Ronnie Jackson, the
guy doesn't even have experience selecting
and conducting these types of tests.
He's the guy who told us Trump is six foot
three and weighs to thirty nine, if you can
believe that.
And even people with mild dementia can actually
pass the Montreal cognitive assessment.
So that's the latest from Ronay.
They're continuing to push this same thing.
And I'm curious to hear from you what you
make of it.
Are they pushing this because they have nothing
else?
Are they pushing it to sort of sort of try
to get back at the concerns about the same
with Donald Trump?
I don't know.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have more on this on the show's Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show